this is a production of Cornell
University one of the wonderful things
about working at Cornell University is
the people you get to work with and I've
had a number of outstanding graduate
students and one of them is dr. Chris
Peters and it's his work that I'm going
to be presenting I've you know I helped
him but with the approach that we've
taken in this work is a modeling study
or a whole series of modeling studies
the work started at Cornell University
and was funded by USDA and later the
Kellogg Foundation and looking over a
whole series of studies what we wanted
to do was determine how many persons
could be fed a complete balanced diet on
land currently in use to grow food crops
with sustainable methods this would be
in the United States and how much land
is needed to feed one person the
research and modeling team involved dr.
Chris Peters who's not Tufts University
in the school of nutrition science and
policy and a number of his graduate
students have contributed to the latter
part of this dr. Jennifer Wilkins was
formerly at Cornell in food science I
now think she's in an endowed chair but
in any case he's at public health and
food studies and nutrition at Syracuse
University dr. art limbo is now Seles
berry University in the science and
technology department he helped us with
a lot of the interface with mapping and
so forth dr. Nelson's bills was in am is
retired and and I'm now retired so we
kind of moved away from from Cornell
University the background on the first
just noticed that that Chris Peters is
the senior author and all the papers I
put up here this is not the complete
list but the other thing they started
publication in 2007 and out of this
funding grant request the last paper
came out
half ago the studies I'm going to look
at today are first of all looking at the
New York State model where we looked at
the diet what we called food prints and
food sheds well define those a little
bit later and the population that could
be fed in New York State with our
agricultural land so what that study was
funded by USDA Kellogg Foundation became
interested in the work we were doing and
then put us funded us to compare New
York State with Michigan New Mexico and
Mississippi and then to look at all 48
states they picked out these four
additional or three additional States
because Kellogg Foundation is interested
in childhood nutrition or malnutrition
and Michigan and major studies going on
in Detroit for inner-city kids in New
Mexico on the Indian reservations and in
Mississippi rural poor and they said
we'll give you money to study all 48
adjacent states if you do these three
next and there's some interesting
studies there and then we went on to
look at all 48 states to compare
balanced diets relative to the
populations that that could be supported
how much food does it take the
information for most of this work is in
published sources and with a lot of
calculation and if you wait the average
size of an American all sizes of people
all ages all genders all physiological
states according to the distribution it
takes 2153 calories or kilocalories per
person to balance the diet and what kind
of diet we actually went back to the
1992 USDA food pyramid my plate looks a
whole lot different but it doesn't show
you this important information of how
many servings you are and you can get
into the footnotes it tells you how many
cups of various kinds of food or what
weight of food so we actually could
start here and work
to agricultural production with the
information provided in the pyramid what
we put into the models finally the last
one is a hundred and eighty six primary
food commodities those are essentially
crops in the USDA database about crop
production in the United States there
are a lot more foods than that but those
are the primary commodities and what is
it
corn shows up in 30 percent of the food
in the supermarket right now so there's
there's some assumptions and
manipulations going on here but we're
going back from these food commodities
to agricultural commodities or actually
crop production and then the USDA and
and other services have also told us
what's a loss from the time it gets out
of the field through storage processing
cooking all of this what is the total
loss and again it's information
available for each one of those kinds of
foods and you end up then with the
weight of food that's consumed and the
interesting thing about this study
particularly when we started back in
just after 2000 is we're linking
agriculture and crop production to human
nutrition and a pretty sophisticated way
using the data that is out there so that
that was was a cool thing and I have not
listed the crops but they're categorized
all the grains all the vegetables the
fruits the dairy products other protein
crops beans lentils and so forth added
fats and sweeteners are the categories
in the diet and one of the statements
that Chris made in the last paper I
showed up there is that land I almost
wanted to say soil is the foundational
resource um it's not the only one you
could argue that water is going to be a
limiting factor or that climate is
becoming a limiting factor but we
focused on the land factor in these
studies
and how do you define sustainable land
use and this you know I didn't come up
with this except when we were in our
earlier discussions I said let's go back
to the land use capability classes from
from NRCS and this is how we'll be fine
lot of sustainable use there are eight
classes of land class one land has only
slight limitations to crop production
class two land has only moderate
limitations class three they say they're
severe and what's happening as you go
down here to one through through skip
five one through four and then six and
seven
generally the slope is increasing so the
land becomes more erosive but there
could be other limitations so anyway you
get out here class five has a set of
limitations that are not easily
corrected it's too shallow too rocky too
wet too steep the growing seasons to
cope as an aside I was crossing when I
was a graduate student traveling from
Nebraska to Davis in California I
stopped the gas up in the Great Basin
mountains all around with lots of snow
and I said why is this in sagebrush why
isn't an irritant in irrigated
agriculture and the guy said we get a
frost 12 months of the year beautiful
looking land plenty of water around for
irrigation but it's going to be in class
five you can't grow crops there anyway
you get down here what are the
management modifications on this well if
you get to class
to land and you use conservation tillage
you can crop it every year even though
it has some slope or you can crop it
only three out of five years in a crop
rotation the other two years it needs to
be in a sod crop essentially pasture
something you could raise but it you
don't need need to graze it but it needs
to be an aside to protect and then you
used conservation tillage on class three
land
or put Assad on it three out of five
years or you can just use it Assad - out
of the five years with conservation
tillage that's how you're reading my
code up there you get to class for land
you only can crop it once and every five
years and so forth you get down here
class six lands only grazing and so
forth the model data we started out in
New York and I'll just show you this
rather than going through those details
this is a map of land using in New York
State we're really interested in the
agricultural use of the land and it
pulls out like this New York State looks
kind of funny here the border the state
is actually down here and they've
extended the border to the American
border next to counted out into the
lakes but anyhow that's where the
agricultural land is in New York State
here's western New York where there is a
concentration of that land so we plugged
in the dietary information the land data
and we we then did the calculations how
many people could you feed and we looked
at different diets the diets we looked
at ran from this this many calories well
wait a minute I'm kidding I'm not going
backwards there we go
we had percent calories from fat that
influences how many people you can feed
and over here is the population you can
feed with just the agricultural land in
use currently in use at its current
night 2010 with different diets with
from 2i0 ounces to six ounces of meat
and the diet and the really interesting
thing about this the surprise is that
the vegetarian diet no meat as you
increase the fat and feed fewer people
producing fat takes more land more more
energy it's photosynthetically not as
efficient if you get right down to the
physiology and actually you look at
these numbers on a vegetarian diet
versus these with two ounces of meat in
the diet you can actually feed more
people
a little bit of meat using the New York
State land base then you can on a
vegetarian dot that was a surprise to a
lot of ecologist and we had to explain
what was going on there the issue is
that because of the nature of the land
in New York State you have all this
unused land and when you get back here
to the zero ounces or Rams a different
scale right there didn't get the scale
changing all my slides I'm I'm sorry but
anyway you've got a lot of unused land
so you're feeding fewer people because
you've got land you cannot use in a
sustainable manner it's just too steep
and as you increase the quantity of meat
in the diet use more and more of the
land with those perennial crops raising
beef cattle sheep dairy cattle on the
steeper Hills and and let's see next
slide so how many people can we feed if
we're looking at this is the 30% calorie
that's in the middle of the table
not the extremes I was talking about
earlier we can feed almost 30% of the
population of New York State in two
thousand in a vegetarian diet and this
is in hectares I'll show you an acre is
a little bit that later on but you see
this is the unused land so the land that
you're using decreases as as you go from
six ounces of meat six ounces it is a
lot so here is the summary and the
extension publication
thank you for crediting me with some
extension work uh and we just you know
use this you talk about what's your
carbon footprint
what what's your land footprint in terms
of food production and this is is the
six ounce diet it takes one point nine
acres per person you want to know the
metric units there in the previous slide
and here's back here zero grams of eaten
and Diet takes half an acre for purse
this amounts this Fed the most people
with the two ounces of beat and that's
equal to about the size of a deck of
playing cards per day a little more than
1/8 and then this one with all that meat
that's three quarter pounders but there
you see there's a huge impact on how
much land it takes based on on your diet
very very interesting work the other
thing we were able to do because of the
way the the maps were coded for New York
State we could see where the food had to
come from and he developed the concept
of the food shed and this shows the area
around major cities in New York that
would feed all the people in that
population center well all the people in
the circle and it turns out that for
most of the cities in New York State we
actually have what amounts to a local
food system that is potentially we're
dealing only with foods produced in New
York what that means there's there's no
oranges and no bananas they got to get
your vitamin C from sauerkraut or
something else or other sources but that
that's one of the assumptions so this is
how it works out and he was developed an
optimization procedure to go with the
model so he minimized the distance that
food had to travel to feed everybody and
he come up with this interesting kind of
map and what you see here's the
population back I estimated I think 2005
for Buffalo and so forth and this is the
percent of the food needs you can meet
for Buffalo Rochester and Syracuse you
can virtually feed all the people with
that local food system and this is the
distance that the food has to travel and
average across the whole state including
New York and Poughkeepsie is just 30
miles but if you put New York City in
there the whole thing blows up you can't
really feed New York City and what the
local food sheds look like are not very
local anymore
because New York City to minimize the
miles is robbing from the other cities
this is what's going on here
so that that was very interesting we had
a lot of local food sheds we could feed
about a third of the people in New York
State with the land that is in New York
State we're always going to have to
improve import food into New York State
with our present populations the next
thing we did was to compare the states
and when I just showed you for it for
New York State we can feed about 1/3 of
the people doing the best we can and
that cows will actually increase the
food supply because it allows us to use
land in a sustainable way that we
otherwise could not when we go to
Michigan
lots of agricultural land no problems
nothing interesting there they could
just feed themselves about anything we
did go to New Mexico big surprise
they've got all this waste land all this
rangeland classified land and new New
Mexico but every cow in the state
reduced the food supply
what's going on cows have to be fed in
the wintertime the winter feed for cows
comes from irrigated land irrigated
alfalfa for the most part every acre of
irrigated alfalfa reduces other food
crops that could have been on that land
so in this land configuration every acre
or every cow in the state actually
decreased the amount of food they were
producing I don't know if the Cowboys
out there would like to hear that but
anyhow that's that's what happens when
the cows compete for the land you've got
some problems ok let's go back to or
continue with our study of the 48
contiguous states adjacent states we're
looking at this human dietary need
complete balanced diet I showed you
those numbers before I was not involved
in the study but Chris and his graduate
students actually developed a more
sophisticated model than we had in the
first one regarding livestock good
livestock feed deed model they were
still 186 different foods and feeds but
the losses calculated the land types and
the area is now in production
this is all potential no changes in
population or land and we wanted this
sustainable cropping system
sustainable land use and so what that
looks like now is what I've showed you
before the eight classes we're saying
this is our definition of sustainable
and with these conservation tillage your
crop rotations and then out here looking
at the whole United States and
subtracting the land using to grow used
to grow cotton tobacco ornamentals and
so forth you end up with ninety five
million hectares in food production in
classes one and two some of class two
maybe in in forage crops actually all of
it could be if you're dedicated to cows
then we have thirty nine million
hectares that we call Grace cropland
that's in in classes three and four
where you need to have cover crops you
don't need to graze them but they're
there and you can and so called that
grace cropland we can grow some crops
some of the time on these categories and
then you get down here and from five
seven really we have two hundred ninety
nine million hectares in permanent
grazing land in the United States that
are as best we could figure out being
used to produce food to get that
this is really important looking at
sustainable land use we have 95 million
hectares of cultivated problem if we're
using conservation telly troops we're
using conservation tillage that's all of
class - if not summer class - will be
down here in this category there are 39
million hectares of grazed cropland this
is land we can grow crops on some of the
time but not all of the time and then
down here classes 5 & 6 299 million
hectares of what amounts to rangeland I
should have put in some picture slides
but to show you what rangeland in New
York State looks like but as you get
close to the Adirondack Mountains you
get shallow soils - - limestone bedrock
and we don't usually talk about range in
New York State I've seen a lot of the
western range and doesn't look any
different doesn't produce any difference
one of the calculations that that they
did in the animal model is what is the
production potential of all this land
and the average based on how much meat
they're producing they didn't go out and
measure the yield was something less
than 700 pounds per acre across that
land but you can use it and can use it
to grow beef or lamb then what we wanted
to do in this study of the 48 adjacent
States was to compare different diets
and I'll go over this several times but
this is the code we have the baseline
diet that's the current way we're eating
right now
USDA has the information then we have a
positive control the POS diet that is we
get rid of the excesses in the diet
we're over consuming calories and we
create a balanced diet formulate a
balanced diet that has a right amount of
calories in it and then we make further
changes we have an omnivorous diet
that's 100% healthy down to 20 percent
healthy omnivorous then we look at
ovo-lacto vegetarian with eggs milk
lacto-vegetarian with milk and the vegan
diet with no animal products at all and
we make those comparisons of how many
people could we feed on those acres in
the United States so this actually looks
at the ten diets in detail right now the
average person in the United States is
concerning
28:44 kilocalories per day and this this
is the animal protein and the vegetable
protein and the calculation how many
acres it takes to feed that person that
died then you drop it down to the 2153
which was calculated an adequate diet
and only change is in the fat and the
diet this is still an excessive protein
diet
according to nutritional standards and
that's why we go from the positive
control
let's just stop over eating calories do
the balanced omnivorous diet which now
we're dropping the protein level to what
the recommendation say we should be
consuming improved and then we just add
more well we start adding
vegetarian components to the diet as we
decrease the omnivorous components and
you can look what's going on and
interestingly the acres per person for
these diets if minimizing acres to feed
one person is your definition of what is
sustainable
the vegan diets the most sustainable and
people think well that's that's the
obvious answer but it's not here are the
populations we actually can feed with
those different diets and this is the
percent of the u.s. cropland that is
used and you see the vegan diet feeds
fewer people than the lacto-vegetarian
diet this was the best one in terms of
feeding number of people because it's
using less land the land sustainability
kicking in if you're not going to have
animals in your system what are you
going to do with those forages you plow
them down hopefully that'll increase the
yields which was not calculated but
anyhow this diet the lacto-vegetarian
this is two hundred and sixty one
percent of the 2010 population of the
United States population in the United
States right now what is that 325 326
million so all of the diets we have a
land base in the United States that
provides more food than we need maybe
that's part of the reason why we're
overeating we've got a food industry
that advertises eat more eat more
because we've cut it to sell I that's
not the only factor I looks like to eat
but anyhow these these are the numbers
of people that we can feed the land area
required and again it takes the leased
land area for the vegan diet but it
doesn't feed as many people how are we
using that cropland we have 95 million
hectares of cropland that that we could
crop and in this baseline diet we're
only using 71 million hectares up not
the base the baseline diet because we
have so much livestock and we're
producing livestock feed and so forth
for the perennial cropland
the unused cropland the neat you know
this is all the cropland lands that
where we can cultivate that we can plow
and we're using all of it and in these
diets but when we get down here because
of the conservation requirement on the
class three and for land less and less
can be used as we're providing more and
more vegetable products into the diet
and you can also see in that two hundred
ninety nine million acres of rangeland
or grazing land when you get down here
just forty percent of the 100 percent
omnivorous diet fraction of that land
we're using starts dropping and we get
down here to the vegetarian diets and
the vegan diet we're not using any of
the Ranger
in the United States now I've put these
numbers in red because the question
comes up and looking at the validity of
this somewhat theoretical you know we're
using published data but are all the
assumptions what they should be what if
we could use this unused cropland for
different crops
that maybe is a clue to how to increase
the food supply in developing new crops
but as a modeler let's just change the
numbers with sensitivity enough and see
what happens is it possible to grow food
crops on the unused perennial cropland
at three classes three and four for the
most part that is more teacups more nuts
more apples and so forth and are not
things that we could put on a fairly
steep land whatever they would be and
how does this affect the rankings and
the analysis no there's a sensitivity
analysis and you can look at everything
but anyway the vegan diet became equal
to the oval lacto and the
lacto-vegetarian diet if we could put
92% of that class three and four land
into crops every year
right now the baseline you know in RCS
is only 71% is there so what is needed
to get to move that way is to have crops
that we can put on that marginal steep
land that produce food in a perennial
way move toward getting perennial cereal
crops and so forth might might help and
of course research is going on in that
area so concluding comments got a lot of
time to talk about this first of all the
diet has a big influence in how many
people that we can feed this is dawn but
this is giving quantitative information
on that particular factor the vegetarian
and vegan diets do take the least amount
of land
if you're concerned about carbon
sequestration and wildland if wild
places for wild animals to live and so
forth of vegan diets good for them but
sustainable use of land now in
production will provide feed for
livestock that will produce meat and
milk in the diet so actually more people
can be fed with - modest amounts of
animal products in in the diet
just looking at that study in New Mexico
I think that's an interesting point
livestock can compete
with food crops for the use of cropland
and so that will reduce the food supply
where that happens if you have a land
resource such as we have in New York
State or Michigan I didn't look in
detail where we have enough marginal
steep land that we can feed our
livestock justing out what their raishin
is then animals are going to increase
the food supply the local food Chad's
oops come back the local food sheds this
is a recent study I just showed you in
New York City blows the thing up and
I've been saying for years as I talk
about this I don't have any idea how
we're going to feed New York City how
we're going to feed Los Angeles and
Tokyo in Mexico City thinking about a
local food system
urban agriculture will make a
significant contribution but they're
still going to have to import food and
Chris's and these graduate students have
looked at other cities on the coast and
if you're only halfway surrounded by
agricultural land or worse than that by
mountains and rocks like New York City a
local food system is not going to be
possible we're going to have to continue
to import food into those big coastal
cities or get people out there I don't
know if you want to think about that the
sensitivity analysis shows that the use
of the cropland pasture has a changes
the results on the ranking we're
assuming what is sustainable land use
so that we've got 39 million hectares of
cropland in the United States the 48
states that have to have a lot of
forages on them for sustainable use if
that could change that would change the
comparison of the different nights and
vegan diet would become more acceptable
the last thing we see this is being
recorded to have to be careful how I say
this but some proponents of the vegan
diet are very suspicious about results
in fact they were almost livid I've
never done any any work that has brought
so much response from the public as this
particular work because people
advocating vegan diets just were sure
that it would feed the most people and
they didn't like the idea that that was
not the most sustainable method you
could use I don't know how you want to
define sustainability certainly the
vegan diet used the lease plan
but it had a lot of unused land that
that affected the results so this is
where I want to stop and I'm given
myself too much time for questions but I
think you get yet the idea of what we
have been been doing and I think it's
pretty interesting it was nice to have
Chris Peters here's my graduate student
and then postdoc and his work I think
who set up his whole career he's getting
grants publishing lots of papers
continuing to work on the modeling of
food systems and he's gotten tenure yes
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu